[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parler bref on va refaire toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
bonjour katia bonjour michael est notre
invité cette semaine nicolas dupont
aignan bonjour bonjour vous êtes
président de debout la france et
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
vous avez présenté votre programme cette
semaine on y reviendra
on va dérouler avec vous le fil de
l'actualité ça commence par des huit
semaines de manuel valls partie de
matignon il a débuté sa campagne par un
meeting dans le doubs il espère être
l'homme du rassemblement
bernard cazeneuve lui a passé sa
première séance de questions au
gouvernement à l'assemblée l'opposition
n'a pas ménagé le nouveau premier
ministre ne met en face à son bilan et
plus ce vote surprise du sénat sur
l'image et les sénateurs ont adopté la
proposition de loi qui a été votée à
l'assemblée nationale et qui pénalisent
les sites d'information sur l'avortement
et commençons par l'actualité politique
avec de ces partis pour manuel valls il
s'est donc lancé dans la course en début
de semaine il a choisi audincourt dans
le doubs pour faire sa première réunion
publique de candidat à l'élection
présidentielle l amont d'un gala et
sofia rosso premier déplacement de
campagne pour manuel valls visites
d'entreprises et d'une coopérative dans
le doubs une circonscription que
l'ancien premier ministre n'a pas choisi
au hasard
il était déjà venu début 2015 dans le
cadre d'une législative partielle très
compliqué pour la gauche
je vous promets une chose c'est qu'après
la primaire si je la gagne je viendrai
ici de nouveau dans le doubs parce que
c'est un fil conducteur qui est celui de
victoire je suis venu ici soutenir deux
fois frédéric barbier qu'en janvier 2015
et ça marche et manuel valls qui affirme
qu'il est le seul à pouvoir rassembler
contre le front national et la droite
même s'il reconnaît avoir pu ne pas
faire l'unanimité dans son camp on me
dit manuel valls vous avez santé non
j'ai toujours voulu rassembler dans la
carte et jesse j'ai participé aux débats
parfois jeu puis avoir des mots durs
suscité des incompréhensions
comme chacun d'entre nous mais j'évolue
je change j'ai une mission bien
évidemment aujourd'hui comme candidat à
la présidence de la république
mais j'ai toujours voulu rassembler mais
le travail commence pour l'ancien
premier ministre qui à un mois et demi
pour convaincre des militants encore
frileux vous aurez vous serez les luttes
d'une gauche dure à face à vous emmanuel
macron et jean luc mélenchon
vous avez dit que vous vouliez vous
dépasser alors prouvez le vous partez
tout le temps de rassembler et ben a
rassemblé fed n'ont fait une seule
primaire avec les trois mais bon à
l'armée mais la prime et c'est à vous de
les convaincre d'arrêter de jouer comme
des gamins à une probable candidature de
vincent peillon manuel valls n'a pas
souhaité répondre
mais pour lui le tout sauf valls ne peut
pas être un motif de rassemblement au
parti socialiste
est ce que vous pensez nicolas dupont
aignan que manuel valls peut assurer une
présence de la gauche au second tour
d'élection présidentielle
moi je pense est comme tous les français
très lassé de ces grands cinémas
je pense surtout que manuel valls a été
le premier ministre de françois hollande
avec un quinquennat catastrophique on a
l'impression que ce sont des images
comme ça qu'ils passent mais derrière il
ya un bilan table il ya des millions de
chômeurs ya mépris du peuple
il ya une soumission à bruxelles il ya
une faillite
enfin dominateurs n'est pas légitime
pour vous mais en tout cas je la
combattrai parce que je veux combattre
ce socialisme qui a abîmé la france et
c'est insupportable pour tous les
français qui souffrent de voir ce jeu
politicien et cette femme elle a exprimé
le ridicule de ridicule de ces images
mais il n'y a aucun examen de conscience
chez zara
aucun examen de conscience et que la
gauche sera au deuxième tour d'élection
présidentielle
mais je n'en sais rien moi je me battrai
pour un projet différent et je crois que
les français aspirent
un grand coup de balai un vrai ménage un
vrai ménage c'est pas parce que
l'emballage est différent que le contenu
est différent c'est le même contenu
c'est la même politique depuis 20 ans
qui a épuisé le pays
il est temps d'en changer est ce que
vous prendriez les mêmes mots que marine
le pen cette semaine et ce sont des
doublures
oui bien sûr ce sont des doublures mais
je peux prendre les mêmes mots que tous
les français
après ça veut pas dire que je veux
marine le pen justement je me présente
pour offrir un patriotisme et confirme
mais là mais on ne me double
par rapport à tous les français l'om
traîne par rapport annuel malgré par
rapport à d'autres c'est certain fillon
mais c'est des gens qui gouvernent
depuis 30 ans qui ont fait exploser la
dette qui ont été responsables du
matraquage fiscal qui sont responsables
de l'immigration massive de la fiscalité
bref le bilan est accablant et on our
cycle le jeu politicien des primaires
fait que on veut faire passer pour 9 ce
qui est vieux
alors alors de grâce parlons d'autre
chose alors parlons notamment de michel
dans les marais qui a déclaré sa
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
qu'est-ce que et qui se présente comme
gaulliste
finalement elle marche un peu écoutez je
ne ferai aucun commentaire sur les uns
les autres à bord qui sera candidat
vraiment michèle alliot marie avait déjà
été candidate et puis il n'avait plus
été je respecte cette femme mais je
pense qu'on ne peut pas se dire
gaulliste
si on ne revoit pas nos rapports avec
l'union européenne avec la politique
étrangère de la france pour restaurer
l'indépendance du pays
seule condition pour traiter la cause
des problèmes du chômage massif de
l'immigration de la pauvreté de masse
qui a dans notre pays
moi j'ai fait un engagement j'ai quitté
l'ump en 2007
pas parce que j'aimais pas mes anciens
collègues parce que j'étais en désaccord
fondamental et malheureusement pour le
pays
tout ce que j'ai dit c'est avéré juste
quand on ne maîtrise pas ses frontières
on contrôle pas son immigration quand on
lutte pas contre la concurrence déloyale
du monde entier ont repris et les pme on
peut pas aider nos pme
moi je veux traiter la cause des
problèmes et je présente aux français le
seul projet qui permettra de sortir le
pays de la crise
ça c'est important beaucoup plus
important que nos milliers des soldes
reste il ya des symboles quand vous
dites que être gaulliste aujourd'hui ce
fait par rapport notamment démarcations
sur l'union européenne a oui parce que
vous estimez françois fillon n'est pas
un gaulliste que mais j'ai pas donner
des leçons soyons clairs je vais pas
donner des leçons des brevets est ce que
vous êtes le seul héritier du gaullisme
dans cette élection présidentielle
prétention parce que c'est aux français
de s'en rendre compte mais en revanche
que je dis c'est qu'il ya des leçons et
la leçon
c'est quand on n'a pas la moitié des
lois françaises qui sont décidés par des
technocrates à bruxelles quand on
contrôle pas ses frontières
quand on a une politique étrangère et
qu'on a réintégré l'otan et ça c'est le
holisme bas excusez moi c'est exactement
l'inversé de ce que voulait le général
de gaulle pourquoi la france
essayant de reprendre les choses à plat
et trop souvent très vite pourquoi la
france s'en est sorti sous de gaulle
c'est pas parce que c'était de boules de
gaulle moi je suis pas pour la nostalgie
je suis pour qu'on regarde les recettes
qui marchent quand on défend les
intérêts du pays
eh bien il ya des conséquences sur
l'emploi sur la relance sur le niveau de
vie et bien moi je veux être président
de la république pour qu'à l'elysée il
ya quelqu'un qui défendent les intérêts
des français
le gaulliste c'est ça oui je pense vers
le sol gaullisme cette élection en tout
cas je défendrai une vision de la france
qui veut rendre aux français le pouvoir
si vous n'avez pas le pouvoir vous êtes
une marionnette et ça fait 30 ans qu'on
a des marionnettes ou pas c'est sur un
autre sujet cette semaine donc manuel
valls a démissionné savez il ya eu un
nouveau gouvernement
[Musique]
ballard cazeneuve a été nommé premier
ministre c'était le baptême du feu pour
lui lors des questions d'actualité
résumé par stéphanie des pierres dans
l'hémicycle sur les bancs du
gouvernement
bernard cazeneuve a changé de place et
il est désormais en première ligne dès
la première question d'actualité
l'opposition attaque le tout nouveau
premier ministre
les français savent que vous ne ferez
rien ou presque dans les quelques
semaines qui nous séparent de l'élection
présidentielle quelle est votre
légitimité politique pour gérer les
affaires courantes
avez-vous ici dans cet hémicycle une
majorité réponse immédiate du chef du
gouvernement
vous me demandez d'où je tire ma
légitimité mais je la tire est bien
entendu monsieur présent la cob du
parlement parce que le conseil des
ministres se réunira samedi qu'il aura à
traiter de la question de l'état
d'urgence qu'il aura traité de ma
déclaration de politique générale et du
vote qui s'ensuivra et qui permettra
soyez en sûrs de vous garantir que je
dispose dans cet hémicycle d'une large
majorité pour poursuivre l'action dont
le pays a besoin
après une longue ovation à la sortie des
questions d'actualité les socialistes
saluent la compétence de bernard
cazeneuve a vu comment il était à la
hauteur
vous avez vu comment il a répondu vous
avez vu comment il connaissait les
dossiers vous avez vu comment il est et
il était pointu moi je trouve que c'est
un très bon et un excellent premier
ministre il ya rien à dire au contraire
et je suis persuadé que le groupe
majoritaire va être derrière lui
l'opposition elle attend le discours de
politique générale prévu marc moi
j'attends de lui en à cazeneuve que les
fameuses 138 jours qui nous séparent du
premier tour des présidentielles soient
efficaces si monsieur personnage doit
continuer la politique catastrophique
que monsieur hollande a mis en place
pour le pays et que monsieur valls a
très bien servi
je reviens mardi l'opposition ne devrait
pas voter la confiance au nouveau
gouvernement
débat de politique générale mardi vote
de confiance ou votre et coire pas je ne
le voterai draps mais attendez si un
martien si un martien débarqué dans
l'hémicycle il se dirait mais les
français sont dingues
au delà de la personnalité de bernard
cazeneuve
c'est quand même l'homme d'un échec
sidérant
des centaines de morts sur le sol
français
des policiers dans la rue una sécurité
incroyable des frontières pas contrôler
des migrants à qui on donne plus
davantage que des français qui
travaillent notamment à l'intérieur mais
c'était le le ministre de l'intérieur
avec le gouvernement mais d'un drame
national et tous prochains mois mais il
n'a pas pris les mesures qui
s'imposaient c'est pas lui
spécifiquement d'ailleurs qu'il y en
avait beaucoup je vais proposer 25
mesures notamment d'arrêter les
djihadistes qui revient de syrie et sur
l'attentât de nice il ya beaucoup à dire
mais on n'est plus une démocratie mais
vous ne verriez jamais cela dans un pays
anglo saxon la promotion de l'échec et
tous les autres ne le sait la promotion
de l'échec et tous les autres qui
applaudissent comme des comme des
pantins
mais on est où on vit où on vit dans
quel pays
mais les français à juste titre je le
redis réveillez vous mais revenez sur
terre
il n'y a pas une entreprise ya pas une
association n'y a pas une télévision où
quelqu'un qui a échoué autant sur le
plan de la sécurité pose pour être
premier ministre
enfin cette acquisition mais c'est la
décrédibilisation total de l'action
publique mais rigueur ce qui est
tragique c'est que les français s'en
fiche complètement puisque c'est pour
quelques semaines et que la vraie
question
les havrais question c'est qu'est ce
qu'on fait après parce que si après
c'est pour revoir une mauvaise droite
qui fait revenir la gauche etc l'essuie
glace depuis vingt ans la mauvaise
gauche la mauvaise droite la mauvaise
droite la mauvaise gauche et bien moi je
me bats je suis candidat pour ça 6 quand
même ça l'essentiel et il nous reste peu
de temps il reste il reste peu de temps
il reste quelques mois mais irréel que
moi pour éviter cinq ans il ya une rare
vivent 50 droite comme on a eu 50 gauche
c'est ça la vraie question
la france est sous état d'urgence
il ya un nouveau gouvernement donc cet
état d'urgence et est caduc de fait il
faut revoter le très bien on va voter
l'état d'urgence mais ça suffit pas ça
suffit pas donc vous fait tant qu'on
contre routière ta d'urgence tant qu'on
contrôle ans je le voterai c'est un
moindre mal et contrôler les frontières
c'est déjà un peu le cas avec mais non
j'étais à la frontière belge a pas
longtemps il n'y a aucun contrôle
tant qu'on ne recrutera pas les
policiers les militaires je propose le
recrutement de 50 mille militaires pour
revenir au niveau
revenir aux niveaux d'avant 2007 je
demande pas la lune nos frontières ne
sont pas contre les femmes et nos
frontières bien évidemment nos
frontières ne sont pas contrôlés nos
armées n'ont pas les moyens de leur
tâche et on les envoie
on a on a des militaires exceptionnels
qui font un travail et des moyens marcal
à la marge il faut retrouver les
effectifs de 2007 nicolas sarkozy
françois fillon
les socialistes ont supprimé 60000
postes de militaires alors il faut
arrêter le mensonge collectif il faut
arrêter l'hypocrisie
il faut maintenant mettre cartes sur
table moi je propose un plan de
redéploiement de la fonction publique
pour recruter les 90000 soixante mille
militaires trente mille forces de
l'ordre interne parce que nous supprime
pas de fonction publique vous supprimez
pas je remets toi je garde le même ne
suprêmement supprime page redéploie
c'est à dire que comme il me faut 90
mille fonctionnaires pour assurer la
protection des français
je les prends ailleurs je redéploie
parce que supprimer sa 106 minutes
ionnaires tous militaires et tous les
policiers gendarmes police de l'air et
des frontières douaniers militaire mais
pas pour avoir prôné ou ce que je veux
et bien sûr les autres effectifs
le viaduc arabe ils sont tous capables
aujourd'hui de faire ce travail
mais non je prends pas les mêmes il ya
des départs en retraite et je recrute
davantage de militaires pour remplacer
ailleurs je pense qu'on ne peut
supprimer que 90 mille postes et je
recrute des militaires en plus je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse aller au delà
d'environ 90 milles c'est à dire ce sont
les gaspillages ici ou là cinq cent
mille c'est une folie qu'est ce qu'on
fait de mal nos policiers nos
infirmières nos fonctionnaires pour
mériter tant de mépris de la part de la
droite tant de mépris nos enseignants
est ce qu'on va supprimer les
enseignants dans les classes
françois fillon c'est une folie c'est
une folie son programme est un contre
sens et que
mickey je dis aux gens de droite qui me
regardent que si on casse la croissance
vous savez françois fillon c'est celui
qui avec nicolas sarkozy a augmenté de
11 milliards les impôts en 2011
en pleine crise ce qui a freiné la vidéo
il fallait surtout pas le faire et c'est
françois hollande car ajouter 40
milliards le matraquage fiscal est là
françois fillon nous dit on va augmenter
deux points la tva
oh vous savez vous pouvez baisser les
charges des entreprises et je veux les
baisser mais à la différence de françois
fillon uniquement sur les entreprises
qui investissent en france mais vous ne
pouvez être efficace que s'il ya de la
consommation si vous mettez la
croissance à l'arrêt les chefs
d'entreprise n'auront pas de commande
donc moi je veux un programme de relance
économique et de production en france
c'est la seule condition pour être
compétitif et relancer l'économie
le propose françois fillon la con sur le
plan économique oui parce que c'est un
vrai débat repassera sur un autre sujet
une autre image a marqué la semaine
jérôme cahuzac condamné à trois ans de
prison ferme sans aménagement de peine
l'ex ministre du budget a décidé de
faire appel de sa condamnation il a été
reconnu coupable de fraude fiscale et de
blanchiment de fraude fiscale
est ce que il prend des risques selon
vous en faisant appel
est ce qu'il est ce que cette peine est
suffisamment exemplaire pour juger pas
commenter les décisions de justice mais
comme auteur d'un rapport parlementaire
sur les paradis fiscaux voleurs de la
république les voleurs de la république
je me réjouie qu'enfin il ya des peines
de prison ferme et je demande qu'on
fasse sauter le verrou de bercy ce que
je réclame depuis des années ça veut
dire quoi
vous savez qu'en france nous sommes l'un
des seuls pays au monde où c'est le
ministre des finances qui décide s'il ya
des poursuites pénales
face à un fraudeur fiscal et cette
affaire la condamnation qui vient là
prouve que quand la justice s'en mêle
elle peut punir sévèrement et je trouve
ça bien il y aura un avant et un après
affaire qu'elle faisait pour vous
attendez de voir si le verrou de bercy
saute
parce que euh c'est pas passé loin de
l'oubli cette affaire vous souvenez je
dis ça parce que monsieur cahuzac était
ministre des finances et qu'il a tout
fait pour éviter
et s'il y avait pas eu un lanceur
d'alerté courageux on n'en serait pas là
donc il ya encore beaucoup de fraudeurs
fiscaux il ya encore à la tête de
l'oligarchie française
beaucoup de gens qui trichent qui vole
alors que
les pauvres français eux ont lé là où
les loups pas quand iman que 50 euros et
moi j'ai dans ma ville des personnes qui
ont fait des procès pour 50 euros alors
que vous avez des grands fraudeurs
fiscaux donc il faut que la justice
passe
il faut que les sanctions implacable
nicolas dupont aignan on va passer à
l'actualité parlementaire au sénat
on parlait de l'hiver et sanctionner les
sites notamment les sites internet qui
est prône lentilles ivg c'était le débat
qui a eu lieu à l'assemblée nationale la
semaine dernière ce débat s'est retrouvé
au sénat cette semaine le vote a été une
surprise regardez ce reportage
début des discussions à gauche comme à
droite personne ne remet en cause le
droit à l ivg ni celui d'exprimer son
désaccord contre la pratique des points
de convergence donc mais la droite
sénatoriale votera finalement contre le
texte ce texte
objectivement ne résoudra rien il ne
sert qu'une fois de plus à réactiver les
peler vous voulez sanctuary zay par la
loi des sanctions contre des agissements
minoritaires et ce faisant une partie de
notre société se sent stigmatisé
on s'achemine alors vers un rejet du
texte alors que la veille en commission
les sénateurs de droite avait décidé de
ne pas prendre part au vote
la majorité sénatoriale est toutefois
divisé certaines interventions empreinte
d'émotion imaginez que vous êtes une
jeune femme entre 16 et 25 ans vous
venez découvrir votre grossesse non
désirée
vous n'osez en parler ni à vos parents
ni à vos proches ni peut-être à votre
ami le temps court il vous reste
quelques semaines ou peut-être quelques
jours et vous chercher de l'info ce que
nous ne pouvons pas accepter c'est
l'idée de se tromper ces jeunes femmes
en avançant de manière masquée je parle
de ces sites
puis c'est la surprise de texte est
adopté à 173 voix contre 126 une version
édulcorée les sites internet ne sont
plus mentionnés le délit d' entrave
arrivée j'ai été tendue à tous ceux qui
par tous moyens cherche à dissuader
d'avoir recours à la pratique
une modification qui pourraient avoir
convaincu certains sénateurs de droite
jusque là réticents nikon a dû provoquer
ce que vous aviez voté la semaine
dernière
moi je suis contre cette proposition de
projet de loi le droit à l'avortement
est un droit dans notre société et je ne
suis pas du tout hostile j'y suis
favorable
en revanche je pense que la liberté
d'expression est aussi un droit et je ne
vois pas au nom de quoi on peut
commencer dans la désinformation qui va
décider de la désinformation
ça devient une société totalitaire et
j'estime que l'on met l'humain la main
dans un engrenage
je suis pas d'accord avec madame keller
je comprends ce qu'elle dit la douleur
c'est des situations très délicates mais
il ya plein de sites d'information qui
explique très bien ce que celle ivg de
manière très correcte et toute personne
peut s'informer mais ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'on va commencer à voter
des lois qui créent des oukases
on n'a pas le droit de regarder tel site
ou tel si vous pensez que ça veut dire à
l'avortement n'est pas menacée en france
et vous ne redoutez pas que certaines
candidats veuillent et un venu orange
en tout cas je pense que c'est un droit
reconnu de tous et là il faudra se
battre s'il y avait le danger mais ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on vote
des lois d'opinion c'est une loi
d'opinion c'est une loi d'interdiction
d'opinion et on va aller jusqu'où alors
après il y aura un autre sujet je suis
pour le droit à l'avortement
bien évidemment j'aurais toujours voté
ces lois mais pour autant il ya le droit
à la liberté d'expression dans notre
pays est-ce que je devrais ce que c'est
une très grave dérive
est-ce que vous toucherez par exemple
aux subventions des associations sur
toutes ces questions je pense qu'on a
trouvé un équilibre dans notre société
et j'aimerais qu'on renforce en revanche
les sites d'information pour la
contraception parce qu'un avortement est
toujours douloureux et je pense que il
ya un droit mais qu'il faut aussi
favoriser l'information notamment des
jeunes dans les lycées sur tous les
sujets qui concernent l'intimité c'est
le parallèle mais cette semaine a eu
deux opinions en accord avec la lame moi
ça voulait dire aujourd'hui
gaulliste ou un gaullisme mais au delà
de la droite et de la gauche qui a
toujours fait de la tolérance de la
tolérance sa marque de fabrique
voilà et mais je n'ai pas dit ça
elle exprime ses convictions est ce que
dans notre pays on peut laisser les
hommes politiques et les femmes
politiques exprimé leurs convictions
et puis les français jugent moi je suis
sur une position équilibrée
alors je vous propose nicolas dupont
aignan d'accueillir maintenant notre
partenaire du figaro.fr jim jarrassé qui
va des corte votre actualité notamment
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est à vous katia bonjour
michael bonjour nicolas dupont aignan on
vient de parler de la position de marion
maréchal-le pen sur les vga la proposer
à la provoqué une controverse au sein
même du front national avec sa tante
marine le pen le pen
hier justement a tenté un peu de se
relancer de sortir de ces sujets en
proposant une proposition choc qui est
de restreindre l'accès à l'école
gratuite aux enfants d'étrangers
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
proposition à commenter les propositions
de madame le pen je suis candidat à la
présidence de la république ça ne
m'intéresse pas est ce que c'est une ce
feu l'insee cga sont gérés de se
relancer
je viens peut souvent chez vous alors
posez moi des questions sur mon projet
pourquoi poser ses compositions
est ce que c'est est-ce que vous avez
des résultats favorables j'ai un projet
d'accord est ce que vous n'avez pas là
justement la sensation d'être un peu
coincé entre françois fillon et marine
le pen
c'est absurde si vous étiez venu à mon
meeting on l'a suivi il avait suivi
vous auriez vu la force des gens leurs
convictions meeting interactive dans
toute la france nous sommes des
gaullistes
nous croyons en l'effort collectif de la
france son indépendance et en même temps
le partage social est plus que jamais
avec le programme de françois fillon eux
il y à la place au contraire pour une
alternative politique ce que j'appelle
l'autre politique serait je me suis
engagé auprès de philippe séguin il ya
vingt ans c'était le rassemblement des
jeunes le rassemblement pour l'autre
politique s'était déjà je me souviens
phillips et leurs revenus un coup qui
avait écrit une tribune magnifique dans
le figaro où dans le monde c'était
tellement si je peux finir ma phrase sur
le munich social munich social c'était
les paroles très fortes à l'égard de
balladur et bien ironie du sort vingt
ans après on n'a pas changé
françois fillon c'est un munich social
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire c'est une
politique déflationniste de matraquage
fiscal qui va tuer l'entreprise sous
prétexte de l'aider il va la tuer c'est
le chemin de la grèce de la déflation
cumulative qui aboutit à en fin de
compte à des déficits plus important
vous avez peut-être suivant meeting vous
avez vu que je propose un programme
économique très original je veux baisser
massivement les charges uniquement sur
les entreprises qui produisent en france
les pme en divisant par deux l'impôt sur
les sociétés mais uniquement celles qui
produisent sur le sol français
j'en ai marre des baisses de charges
pour les entreprises qui délocalisent
mais euh je finis juste et je veux
relancer le pouvoir d'achat en
récupérant l'argent qu'on verse à
bruxelles et le donner aux retraités
avec moi 6 millions de retraités auront
100 euros de plus par mois sans que ça
coûte un centime à l'état
comment les 8 milliards qu'on donne à
bruxelles pour financer nos concurrents
qui viennent nous piquer nos emplois eh
bien je les rends retraités français
pour qui vivre dans la dignité et je
relance le pouvoir d'achat je relance
l'économie locale entend bien tout ça
c'est un changement majeur alors vous ça
vaut bien plus que les propositions de x
ou y eu pour faire du buzz
on attend vos propositions mais sur
votre hôte et fondamentale on attend vos
propositions votre créneau mais vous
avez sur votre façon de présenter
françois fillon comme le candidat de
l'ultralibéralisme vous avez les mêmes
mots que marine le pen est assassiné par
les déblais n'apporte se démarquer mais
pourquoi c'est drôle mais je vous en
veux pas la politique c'est pas des
créneaux on n'est pas dans des marques
de yaourt
on est dans l'avenir de la france moi je
vous dis une chose si françois fillon ou
manuel valls sont élus on en rit on
repart pour cinq ans d'une politique
suicidaire de régression sociale et de
déclin économique imposé par l'union
européenne ça veut dire que je dis aux
français qui me regardent
fais gaffe si vous partez pour cinq ans
fera pas venir vous plaindre et je suis
le seul à proposer une politique
alternative sérieuse sans les excès du
front national ou de monsieur mélenchon
eux il ya trois anti système en france
réelle il ya monsieur mélenchon il ya
madame le pen et ya moi je suis moins
connus que les autres mais j'ai le
programme le plus
sérieux avec des gens équilibrés qui
sont élus localement et je défends une
autre politique ne voulais pas qu'elle
raille la joie du territoire pensé que
vous pouvez batman oui oui je suis
convaincu que les médias et le petit
système politique français ps
républicain adore madame le pen en fait
parce que ça leur permet au dernier
moment de toujours gagner
on l'a vu au moment des régionales et je
pense que le jour où il ya un
patriotisme serein sérieux avec des gens
équilibrés qui ont des propositions
concrètes qui émergent
eh bien les français se diront enfin on
peut se débarrasser de ceux qui nous
font du mal et on va pas continuer
éternellement à voter pour des gens qui
font plus penser on pour autant passer
au front national
vous êtes oui je suis le vote utile
parce que c'est la première alternative
patriotique sérieuse aux médias vous
serez au second tour face à un candidat
avait choisi ce thème entre guillemets
je vais me battre pour être second tour
et je répète à tous les français une
rencontre arrêtez de voter pour des gens
qui vous font du mal ça fait 30 ans que
vous voter pour des gens qui vous font
du mal quand est ce que vous allez
arrêter et je vous propose un projet qui
va nous redonner de l'espérance
j'ai un programme par exemple si on peut
être que les gens regardent de 6 kg est
derrière vous avec qui vous pouvez
gouverner ce oui là-bas c'est beaucoup
mieux avec i beaucoup mieux que ceux qui
ont gouverné depuis 20 ans comme
gouverneur et louis avec des élus locaux
qui sont réélus c'est curieux eux à 80 %
des voix régulièrement il fait des
groupes parlementaires et à leur esprit
ils seront élus députés ne croyez pas
qu'ils aient besoin de ménager besoin de
changer un peu tout ce qui succède et
conques ont ruiné le pays qui se
réveille premier ministre si jamais vous
étirer la ville avait déjà été tué
vous avez choisi a l'embarras du choix
une minute la dernière question une
actualité de la semaine c'est le
référendum italien porté par matteo
renzi qui a été rejetée vous avez
félicité beppe grillo mon ami d
mode c'est votre ami il ferait un bon
premier ministre pour l'italie oui et je
serais heureux savez il ya une photo
amusante et prémonitoire
je pense nous étions à bruxelles avec
beppe grillo avec nigel farrage il ya
quelques années on nous regardait de
haut et il ya cette photo et je pense
que les peuples européens n'en peuvent
plus d'une mauvaise europe qui nous tue
quand on voit les américains qui
choisissent leur destin qui vont
relancer leur économie qui vont protéger
vis-à-vis de la chine et nous on se vend
à la chine on se vend mais on va arrêter
de vendre notre pays par morceaux et il
va falloir en finir avec cette mauvaise
europe en revanche c'est le deuil 30
salle du grès ans oui tout à fait ça
veut dire qu'il va falloir reconstruire
une europe parce que moi je veux pas le
fric site
je veut renégocier les traités je veux
des baux traiter ce qu'on a fait avec
airbus
on peut le faire pour la lutte contre le
cancer l'europe des nations et des
projets projet a peu de pays
et là vous ferez mais le rock et bien
même sens libre et une europe utile et
dont va scruter sur ce lien nicolas
dupont aignan merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité nom se retrouve la semaine
prochaine bonne semaine à tous
[Musique]